hi Jamie how are you hi Dave how are you
doing better than I deserve what's up
awesome well I've got kind of in a
quandary I recently took a job about
three three months ago and prior to that
I had always worked two jobs my first
job I worked for about 20 years it was a
part-time seasonal I did taxes and then
my second job was my professional job
but I went to school for and I worked at
my last job for for 11 years so I took
on a job I'm sorry I took on a job and
at a charter school didn't work out so I
left that job and then I took this job
the second job but my boss is is she's a
doctor Haeckel said mr. Hyde kind of
thing and so I'm kind of in a quandary
because it's not in my nature to be
jumping jobs and this would be like my
third job in three years but I do want
to find a place where I can settle and
sprout my roots and you know really be
something in my industry however I feel
really bad that I've got these desires
to leave because my boss is just is just
something else so I don't and I've
spoken to my husband he's as well you
know do whatever makes you happy and
I've been reading books and and like I'm
reading a John máxima book on the 17
invaluable invaluable laws and it and it
talks about growth and growth plan and
growing myself however we just had a
leadership meeting where we you know
they spoke about characteristics that we
want to avoid and all of these were my
boss and she sees like you're talking
about somebody else and doesn't see any
room to grow so and since I've been
there I've found out that she does not
stay along with her for her complete
office staff she's been there for about
15 16 years and her staff is only two
years less than two years old everybody
so I'm kind of like I don't know what I
need to do what field are you in oh I'm
in child nutrition for the school
districts
okay so those are those jobs aren't
everywhere no they're not everywhere and
usually like right now the open season
has pretty much passed as cool years
start you know getting ready to start
any vacancies or anything like that
you at my level have already been you
know all those transitions have already
taken place I'm perfectly okay as an
employer looking down and seeing someone
has had several jobs as long as there's
a reasonable expectation a reasonable
explanation for that what I'm going to
ask you about if I'm interviewing you is
I'm going to try to figure out if
there's a pattern and the common
denominator of all these failures is you
if I'm interviewing you and that's not
what I'm hearing in the way you're
explaining this you didn't tell me
you're every job you've had was a bad
boss oh no if every job you had as a bad
boss that means you're a bad employee
right that doesn't mean you have bad
bosses so that's how I would look at it
if I were interviewing you in other
words so but if you know if you just got
yourself into an untenable situation you
just got decide how long you're willing
to stay there and what you're willing to
put up with right see and it's like you
know I've come from you know two really
good bosses were you know my part-time
seasonal job was 20 years and you know
my last major job in the field was you
know 11 years long so you know my record
is that I stay in do I stay where I'm at
yeah I bloomer I'm planted but so I
think what you've got is you probably
have to leave but you're going to just
time that in such a way that it works
for you if you see a light at the end
the tunnel and say okay by spring if I
can't get this turned around I'm out of
here
you give her some you talk to her and
you give her some chances to turn and if
it doesn't work you just you get out
you